you and your kids in Gucci and Versace I
mean yeah okay my kids never look like
that they're usually always like Punky
Brewster like they look like totally
disheveled usually but they're they we
got it together today Cal you are
cemented in history what does this honor
mean to you wow how you just said it
kind of freaked me out that's crazy I
didn't really think about it like that
but it's incredible I mean you know
you've seen these pictures since you
were a kid like right with all these
major people that influenced you like
artistically in your life and it's cool
to be a part of that and especially like
right in front of where I won 20 years
ago that's cool they put the star here
um and I don't know it's it's I'm also
in between Harry Potter and Deadpool
which is awesome that could not be
better representations of my personality
magic and sarcasm um yeah so I don't
know and my whole family's here I love
having my kiddos here and my family my
son is slowly taking his Trident apart
that's that's a sign that we should wrap
it up
um that's their way of playing the music
your sweet kiddos were cheering for mom
on the bench what do they think about
this star they don't really get they're
like are they where are these my son
thought there was a parade and he was
like why is there a parade I was like
there's what and he was like there's a
bunch of people he's like oh I think
they're here maybe for this and so they
don't really get it quite yet which I
love but they you know he was over there
playing with his Aquaman tried it the
whole time but years from now they can
come see this which has got to be pretty
cool yeah that's kind of cool yeah have
the Waterworks hit you yet today oh my
God Jason got me or John better known as
John they missed of his name today which
we're the band will never let him live
that down please welcome to the stage
Kelly's good friend John Halbert
Jason Halbert
the day Kelly is receiving the
2733rd star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame Reverend Remy thank you guys so
much for sharing your mom
you don't know now how cool she is but
you're gonna look back on this one day
she's not normal she's incredible and
you guys are so lucky he got me I think
you know it's having someone like be
such a partner in your in your I mean
he's been through everything with me
like my life like the ups and downs of
it like behind the scenes in front of
the camera like it was really cool to
have him specifically here to to to do
that and then to have Simon and then
Paul and Randy here like this was my
start you know and so it was it was
really cool and Simon we got to we got
to talk about something I guess I said
to him years ago that I totally forgot
foreign